all right I posted this to my Twitter
yesterday and so many people were
insanely triggered by it as many of you
heard former democratic congresswoman
Tulsi gabbard announced that she was
leaving the Democratic party earlier
this week not a surprise she's been a
right-wing reactionary for a long time
she also started a podcast
I came across it it looks like she just
copied our logo I mean straight up it
just looks like she copied our logo we
have both logos up on the screen right
now
um the David packman show the Tulsi
gabbard show the concept is exactly the
same as our logo it is a sort of square
logo slightly rectangular with the and
show in perfectly vertical
non-italicized text and then much like
in our logo where David Pacman is
slightly italicized and at an angle it's
the exact same with Tulsi gabbard now I
posted this to my Twitter
70 seriously thirty percent ingest I
mean it's clearly our logo I'm not
claiming to have a copyright on on
slanted italicized text the tool C
stands or tool sells or whatever you
want to call them
they went nuts coming out of the
woodwork saying David you're a shill you
don't own copyright on italics you're a
disgusting person
these folks are so triggered guys it's
sort of a joke but also it does seem
like someone copied our logo relax okay
we're just having a good time and by the
way the podcast the Tulsi gabbard
podcast it sounds like Ben Shapiro I
mean the idea that she was genuinely a
Democrat it's a pathetic joke